so uh does the trump campaign or anyone
involved in trump campaign have anything
to do with this no
that's another thing the liberals like
oh you just do what donald trump wants
if you say if you're saying that about
me then you don't know me pretty well
you don't know me all that well that's
not that's not
the president has nothing to do uh with
this campaign
if you wanted to be a part of the
lawsuit i would i wouldn't say no
i could because i think the pr i
supported the president i i think he's
done an
unbelievable job for this country and
i'll tell you he hasn't been given a
fair shake not at all
definitely not at all and it that that
to me is a travesty and i'll tell you
like i don't want to get too much too
off topic but
seeing the shift and how the media
treated president trump for four years
to now how they're treating
uh joe biden is sickening and they're
shameless
what they've been saying ridiculous they
said donald trump they all have this new
line they're pushing where they said
donald trump was like drinking tabasco
for four years
all right oh i saw yeah they keep using
that line joe biden is like sipping
unflavored almond milk
and my response was actually joe biden
is like when you when you're like really
thirsty so you like go to the fridge and
you're like you know maybe after a
workout and you open the fridge and
there's nothing in there just milk and
you're like i just drink the milk you
grab it you crack it you start chugging
it
and all sudden you notice something
thick and you're like wait there's a
chunk in there yeah
and you pull it down and you just screw
it oh it's spoiled and then you run in
the sink and start barfing all over the
place
that's like vitamins that actually is
the perfect analogy
the people who voted for him not
realizing what he was and now
there was a poll that there was a poll
that came out today that said something
like
gosh i couldn't i couldn't quote it uh
but was it there was a news buster's
poll
yes about you know like if 50 percent of
the people didn't know about the hunter
biden story if they knew about it nine
percent of the people would would shift
their vote away from them and that's
that's a real problem even not even that
they didn't know the record economy they
didn't know about energy independence
they didn't know about the peace deals
they didn't know about the troop
withdrawal
and when presented that information they
all said oh i would have voted for that
so the media keeping all of that not
reporting on it
was helping joe biden we all knew it was
helping joe biden we said it was helping
joe biden and there you go
and look you you peop people
people are treated like they're
conspiracy theorists if they're
suspicious of an election now look
we've never done mail-in ballots on the
scale that we've done in this course
it's the first time it's ever been done
president trump is
more popular today than he was in 2016.
10 million more people voted for him tim
he did better with
african-americans he did better with
latino americans
you if you told me in 2016 that
president trump was
10 million more people were going to
vote for the guy but it wasn't going to
be enough because joe biden was going to
get 80 million votes are you kidding me
are you kid 11 million more than obama
that's crazy at the height of his
popularity right right and i'm sorry
president obama and look again like
people people make the mistake of
thinking like i'm a blindly partisan guy
president obama it was a movement right
oh definitely people people have lost
people loved president obama don't tell
me for a second that joe biden was more
popular than president obama at the
height of his popularity
you could see people can see things
people can
connect the dots on their own and draw
draw suspicions the argument the
argument there is though that it's
actually no one cares about binding they
were voting against trump so that's what
they say but that
that's what the media says to him but i
don't buy it because you know
i don't need that you know well not
completely at least a dislike of
president trump
doesn't drive what like 80 million
people to the polls now
here here so people are seeing things
like this so in allegheny county
uh that's pittsburgh right 85 of which
is you know 85
of allegheny county north of the city of
pittsburgh is in my district now
joe biden got the second highest voter
turnout in allegheny county in the
history of this country second oh
wow second only to lyndon b johnson and
well i mean in 1964
okay when 30 percent more people lived
in
allegheny county wow 30 percent more
populous
and but he got he got the second highest
vote total just a couple thousand votes
but so people are
rightfully suspicious of that process
and then you combine that
with mail-in voting and it makes people
wonder
like 70-plus million people in this
country and this is part of the reason
why
this lawsuit is so important because if
we don't
set some parameters to our electoral
system in this country
right 70 plus million people in this
country will never trust an election
again
i don't i don't think they will i think
we're at you know i'm seeing people say
there's some people saying
don't vote republican in georgia that's
because yeah i know because the
republicans aren't supporting trump
then i'm saying other people say no no
don't give up you have to stop them from
taking
the senate but uh a lot of people are
just saying why
if they cheated now they'll cheat then
what's the point well so
the the point is for number one we can't
allow that to happen because our country
means something our country is the great
greatest benevolent force that's ever
existed on the face of the planet
our country is a bright beacon of hope
for people you know i want my kids to
grow up in a country that is as rich
with opportunity
uh and and vibrant and free like a
country that i had
when i was a kid i want my kids to be
able to put a skate park in their
freaking garage if they work hard enough
right yeah i want that for my kids but
right now that's that's at risk
and so yeah you know people are like
it's funny how
like people treat me like you know i
think publicly at least the left like
i'm just some sort of run-of-the-mill
politician that like would love to make
a career in government
like i've got a pretty great life in the
private sector you know the president
called me off the sidelines like when
you know
serving the people of the state of
pennsylvania or the commonwealth of
pennsylvania or the people of pa 17
would be the greatest honor of my life
i'm in this for service right
me winning a congressional seat in
western pennsylvania means a pretty
significant pay cut for me
i'm not in this for for the money i'm in
this to serve the people and you have
served
and i have served and here's but here's
the thing tim my the point that i'm
building to
is that the people at this point in time
in this country
don't have a choice we have to fight
because if we
lose those two senate seats in georgia
this country will never look the same
again you can bet
that the democrats will pack the court
why because they've said they were going
to pack the court you can bet that the
democrats with control
of all three branches of government will
add two more states why because they've
said they were going to add two more
states and they want to make sure
republicans never went again
absolutely you could bet that the
electoral college will go away forever
why
because they said the electoral college
will go away forever
we have to we have to win those two we
have to win those two senates each in
georgia and and
if we win those two senate seats in
georgia i think we'll likely pick up
more seats in 2022 but in the meantime
in the meantime we have to fight to
protect
our electoral system so make sure that
people have faith in them so
yeah i'm willing to get up on the
parapet and take shots from republicans
and democrats because you know
you know the republicans are mad at me
because the the pa state legislature
that passed act 77
were largely republican control and
again i don't think they knew that was
unconstitutional i think that they were
just trying to make the system better
i don't i don't know if i agree if they
were if they started the process and
then backed off of it sounds like they
knew it was unconstitutional it sounded
sounds to me like they went hey wait a
minute we need an amendment we're not
going to be able to pass this amendment
because
no one's going to approve of it so just
ram it through well what they did that
is damning evidence we make the
distinction in our lawsuit is that
they changed the name from absentee to
mail-in
right so but what they did was make a
distinction
and we make this case they made a
distinction
without without there being a difference
if that makes sense
right so yeah they just claim the
distinction but they're the same thing
and so the the the idea is
you know and so i'll also make another
point you know and this is a message to
the
if i if if act 77 is in fact deemed
unconstitutional and i
i really hope and pray that that it will
be
president trump was the first president
to win the state of pennsylvania since
ronald reagan
the first republican yes yeah the first
republican
to win since ronald reagan and in
it after 2016 between 2016 and 2020
the in the pa state legislature said you
know what let's just change the whole
system
right it's the weirdest thing you know
you know there
if there was if people were if there was
some structure to our electoral system
in pennsylvania right
um i think
president trump still wins i don't think
attorney general shapiro wins
i i think i you know i probably i win
you know
the mail in ballot program and and
here's another thing
i don't think that the republicans in pa
state legislature expected
governor wolf to remove every safeguard
that makes mail-in voting safe i think
that's a very important point to make
he removed the deadline he removed the
postmark requirement he removed
signature verification
he watered down the integrity of the
ballot so much
that how could you possibly verify
who's sending in the voters the person
actually voting and so
yes tim people are rightfully skeptical
of this election and i don't think that
i don't think that's a problem or a
conspiracy theory well there's a there's
a lot of evidence that fraud occurred
there's a lot of evidence of
irregularity there is according to the
voter integrity fund have you heard of
those these guys yes
according to them it's i don't want to
put words in their mouth but
what they're asserting is widespread
voter fraud that they found in georgia
a thousand plus votes that had
commercial addresses with apartment
numbers listed
to trick essentially the system into
thinking these non-residential addresses
were actually residential
sounds like that person should not like
is not a real person voting
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you